Let's go ahead and start R. The
first thing you'll see in the R
console is the version
of R you are using,
and other basic
information related
to licensing,
citations, and demos.
To clear the console,
you can simply
go to Edit and
select Clear Console.
We'll start by reading in
our dataset USDA.csv, which
contains all foods in the USDA
database in 100-gram amounts.
You should have already
downloaded the dataset
to your computer.
To be able to read
the dataset in R,
we first need to navigate to
the directory in our computer,
where the data file,
USDA.csv, is saved.
To do so, if you are on a
Mac, go to the Misc menu,
and select Change
Working Directory.
If you are on a PC,
go to the File menu,
select Change Directory, and
then navigate to the folder
where you saved the csv file.
Then press OK.
Nothing has happened
in R until now,
except changing the
working directory.
To double-check that we are in
the right working directory,
we can type getwd, which stands
for get working directory,
and then R gives us the path
to the folder we just selected.
Now we should be ready
to read in our dataset.
We will use the
function read.csv,
since the dataset was given
to us in a csv format.
And let's save the output to a
data frame, and call it USDA.
And this is equal to read.csv,
and this takes, as an input,
the name of the csv file, which
is USDA.csv, and don't forget
the quotation marks around
the name of the csv file.
Pressing Enter, R now read the
information from the dataset,
and saved it to the
data frame, USDA.
Now it's time to
learn about our data.
We can use the structure
function, or str in R,
and give it the input USDA.
This gives us the
following information.
We have 7,058 observations,
or foods in our dataset,
along with 16
different variables.
The first variable gives a
unique identification number
for each of the foods,
starting with the number 1,001.
The second variable
gives a text description
of each of the foods.
The third variable is
the amount of calories
in 100 grams of
these foods, and it's
given to us in kilocalories.
Then we also have information
about the protein,
total fat, carbohydrate,
saturated fat,
and sugar levels in
grams, as well as
the sodium, cholesterol,
calcium, iron, potassium,
and vitamin C levels,
in milligrams.
And finally, the amount of
vitamin E and vitamin D in what
is known as international
units, and this
is a standard measurement
for drugs and vitamins.
Now to obtain high-level
statistical information
about our dataset, we can
use the summary function,
and give it, as an input,
the USDA data frame.
The summary function
gives us information
such as the minimum, the
maximum, and the mean values
across all 7,058 foods for each
of the 16 different variables.
For instance, the maximum
amount of cholesterol
is 3,100 milligrams, whereas the
mean is only 41.55 milligrams.
We also have information
about the number
of non-available entries.
For instance, we
have 1,910 foods
that are missing entries
for their sugar levels.
Now, scrolling through
this information,
a startling observation
is the maximum level
of sodium, which is
38,758 milligrams.
This number is huge, given that
the daily recommended maximum
is only 2,300 milligrams.
Let's investigate this variable
further in our next video.